Schönen Abend. Karakulak ist mein Name und ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt auf diese Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, wenn ich.
Also bevor wir über Ihre Aktellenbeschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nadine Stegemann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, Nadine schreibt sich N-A-D-I-N-E. Nadine Stegemann S-T-E-G-E-M-A-N-N. Stegemann.
Frau Stegemann, oder?
Ja, Frau Stegemann.
Frau Stegemann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 17. Mai 1971.
71. Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Und wie viel wiegeln Sie zurzeit?
66 kg.
Okay.
Frau Stegemann, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ungefähr seit 4 Stunden.
Da habe ich Schmerzen im Brustkorb auf der linken Seite mehr.
Also das zieht vom Rücken bis vorne hin zum Brustbein.
Die ganze linke Seite tut mir weh.
Und besonders merke ich das auch, wenn ich tief atme
und wenn ich mich bewege, schmerzt das noch mehr.
Ich musste vor Ihnen husten, das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Okay.
Ja, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ah, okay.
Frau Stegemann, haben Sie auch Luftnoten?
Luftnoten nicht.
Aber wenn ich tief einatmen möchte, dann am Ende,
beim tiefen Einatmen, dann schmerzt das stärker.
Okay.
Also, Frau Stegemann,
ich muss jetzt unsere Geschippbrüche unterbrechen
um Ihre Viteilparameter kontrollieren.
Also ich meine Ihre Heskrasen,
Ihre Sauerstoffstätigung und
ja, also außerdem werde ich eine IK geschrieben.
Okay.
Wenn alles in Ordnung wäre, würden wir unsere Geschippbrüche fortsetzen.
Ja, können wir gut machen.
Okay.
Ach, ja, Frau Stegemann,
könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpfstechend oder ziehend?
Hier sind wir mehr so stechend.
Also, das ist so mehr so ein heller Schmerz.
Und wie gesagt, wenn ich so tief Luft holen will,
auch ich wage gar nicht zu husten.
Ich habe zurzeit so einen leichten Husten.
Und wenn ich huste, dann tut das noch mehr weh.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkala,
wobei 1 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen bedeutet?
6.
6, okay.
Und Sie haben erwähnt,
dass diese Schmerzen nach Rücken,
ausstrahlen oder habe ich die Verschaltung?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie in den Rücken ausstrahlen
oder aus dem Rücken kommen.
Es tut jedenfalls die ganze Seite weh,
hinten an der Brustwirbelsäule und vorne.
Und ja, das zieht sich so rum.
Und es ist unangenehm.
Ich kann gar nicht auch auf der Seite so liegen.
Ich wollte mich hinlegen.
Und auch das, auf der Seite liegen,
das tat mir auch weh.
Das habe ich dann lieber nicht mehr gemacht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Haut etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Auf der Haut?
Ja.
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Nein?
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Stegermann?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Ich habe mich eigentlich ganz wohl gefühlt.
Ich habe vorhin Tennis gespielt.
Und ob das mit den Tennisspielen zu tun hatte,
jedenfalls direkt nach der Tennis am Ende
dieses Tennisspiels,
da fing das zu haben mit den Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel, Frau Stegermann?
Nein, nein, mir ist nicht übel.
Okay.
Frau Stegermann,
beim Bewegenden haben Sie auch Schmerzen, oder?
Also wenn Sie Ihre Arme bewegen.
Ja, wenn ich den Linken so hochheben will,
dann merke ich auch, dass das mehr wehtut.
Und wenn ich mich so drehen will,
haben Sie auch Lehmung oder Straflosigkeit?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Taubheißgefühl oder Krippen haben Sie?
Nein.
Ob ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Also ich dokumentiere alles, was Sie erwähnen.
Deshalb bitte ich Sie um etwas gewirrt.
Ja.
Okay.
Ist in Ordnung.
Und Frau Stegermann,
haben Sie hässrasen häss klopfen oder häss stolpen bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihnen,
Herr Frau Stegermann,
haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme.
Nein?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit auch dazu genommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht immer gehalten in letzter Zeit.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Normalerweise kann ich gut schlafen.
Doch.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Ich vertrage bis auf Erdbeeren und Kiwi vertrage ich alles.
Erdbeeren vertrage ich nicht so gut und Kiwi vertrage ich nicht so gut.
Kiwi und Erdbeeren.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer
Krankenfolge, Frau Stegermann.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel Skokrankheit, Bruthochdruck
oder Schiffdruck, das funktioniert?
Ja, ich habe seit vier Jahren ungefähr,
nehme ich ein Medikament ein gegen erhöhten Blutdruck.
Ja, das muss ich einnehmen.
Mit dem Medikament ist der Blutdruck ganz gut eingestellt.
Okay.
Und außer dieser Blutdruck haben Sie auch chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich muss auch noch ein Schilddrüsen-Medikament nehmen,
weil ich bin an der Schilddrüse operiert worden.
Und sonst habe ich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Wann war diese Operation?
Die Schilddrüsen-Operation war vor sechs Jahren.
Vor sechs Jahren.
Okay.
Die Schilddröse war vergrößert und hatte auch zwei Knoten.
Und da hat man die Ärzte gesagt, das muss operiert werden.
Und es war aber alles gutartig.
Und es ist die Schilddröse weitgehend entfernt worden,
nur ein kleiner Rest ist geblieben,
aber ich muss deswegen immer ein Medikament nehmen.
Okay, okay.
Also außer diese Krankheiten haben Sie noch andere Krankheiten?
Frau Stegermann?
Nein.
Bluthochdruck und Schilddröse?
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Also gegen Bluthochdruck und gegen diese Schilddröse?
Ja, ich nehme gegen den hohen Bluthoch ein Medikament ein,
das heißt Rami-Pril.
Wie viel Medikament wissen Sie, die Dosierung?
Ich meine, da steht fünf hinter.
Ich habe jetzt in der Aufregung meinen Zettel vergessen,
aber ich glaube fünf.
Und da nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine.
Okay.
Und Schilddröse unter Funktion, was nehmen Sie?
Ja, das Medikament, das heißt Ältiroxin.
Ältiroxin 50, nehme ich da eine Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie außer diese Medikamenten regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein.
Uns nehme ich nichts ein.
Okay.
Außer diese Schilddröse-Operation,
haben Sie noch andere Operationen gehabt?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Da war ich um etwa zehn Jahre alt.
Und ich, Leistenbruch, war operiert.
Auf der linken Seite, da war ich vielleicht 12 Jahre.
12 Jahre, okay.
Also, haben Sie Allergien, war auch Stegermann?
Ja, ich sagte schon, Erdbeeren vertrag ich,
gut, da kriege ich manchmal so einen Ausschlag am Mund und so Bläschen.
Und Kiwi auch, da brennt mir die ganze Schleimort im Mund.
Also, ob das eine Allergie ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin sonst auch mal getestet worden,
da hat man aber nicht mehr gefunden.
Also Kiwi und Erdbeeren.
Okay.
Und jetzt hätte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihnen.
Lebensgeheunheit, Frau Stegermann,
brauchen Sie?
Nein, mich rauchen, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ach, super, Frau Stegermann.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke mal so am Wochenende mal ein Glas Wein,
vielleicht ein bis zwei Gläser dann eben pro Wochenende,
aber in der Woche trinke ich gar kein Alkohol.
Also am Wochenende trinken Sie Glas Wein?
Ja, ein bis zwei Gläser.
Und noch, was haben Sie gesagt?
Sonst nichts, sonst nichts.
Okay, okay, am Wochenende.
Und bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht per so eine Frau Stegermann,
das ist eine ultimäßige Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport, Frau Stegermann?
Ja, Tennis.
Ich spiele zweimal in der Woche Tennis.
Und das mache ich schon ganz lange.
Ja.
Und so einmal in der Woche versuche ich auch zu joggen,
so eine halbe Stunde, dreiviertel Stunde.
Wenn das Wetter mal schlecht ist, dann habe ich dazu keine Lust.
Aber üben wir mich.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatus, Frau Stegermann?
Sind Sie vollständig?
Also ich war jetzt gerade im Frühjahr bei der Hausärztin,
die hat den Impfpass angeschaut und hat gemeint,
wenn ich jetzt keine großen Fernreisen machen möchte,
oder so, dann ist alles in Ordnung.
Dann brauche ich keine Impf-.
Egen Corona, sind Sie auch vollständig?
Ja, da habe ich insgesamt vier Impfungen.
Okay.
Und besuchen Sie jeder Frau, ist sie regelmäßig Frau Stegermann?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorge und Besuchungen.
Die Periode ist in letzter Zeit etwas unregelmäßiger geworden.
Aber die Frauenärztin sagt, ja, das kann jetzt passieren
in meinem Alter, dass das jetzt schon mal unregelmäßiger wird.
Aber sie sieht da kein Problem drin.
Und wenn mir das nichts ausmacht, sagt sie auch.
Okay, also ich nehme an, dass jeder letzter Vorsorge-Untersuchung
ist unauffällig.
Ja, das war im Juni.
Okay.
Und jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu jeder Familienfrau Stegermann.
Leben sind die Eltern noch?
Ja.
Okay.
Der Vater ist mit 80 Jahren verstorben.
Im Alter ist er nicht mehr.
Im Alter von 80 Jahren hat er einen Schlaganfall.
Schlaganfall?
Ja, daran ist er versteckt.
Und die Mutter, die lebt noch, die ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die hat eine schwere Atrose in der Hüfte und im Knie,
beides links.
Aber sie möchte sich nicht mehr operieren lassen.
Sie geht am Rollator.
Okay, wissen Sie, ob Ihr Vater an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen
gelitten hat?
Der Vater hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und ja.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister Frau Stegermann?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und er hat einen Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt.
Und ich habe eine Schwester, die ist jetzt bald 55 Jahre alt.
Die ist soweit, ich weiß gesund.
Ah, super.
Okay.
Und Frau Stegermann, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Verkäuferin in einer Kon-di-Torei.
Kon-di-Torei?
Nein.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Familienstand, Frau Stegermann?
Ich bin ledig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder, Frau Stegermann?
Nein.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer Beschwerden zurückkommen,
Frau Stegermann.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie beim Einatmen Schmerzen haben.
Haben Sie auch bei der Belastung Luftnot?
Ich habe mich jetzt seit, ich habe ja Tennis gespielt vor 3, 4 Stunden.
4 Stunden war das.
Ich habe Tennis gespielt.
Und am Ende dieses Tennis Spiels, da merkte ich,
dass da im Rücken, was nicht in Ordnung ist,
dass das so sieht hier.
Und danach habe ich nichts Besonderes gemacht.
Ich habe geduscht und habe mich umgezogen.
Und dann wurden die Schmerzen aber eher schlimmer und nicht besser.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ich habe mich seitdem aber nicht belastet.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ob es bei Belastung schlimmer wird.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in den Halsbereich oder in dem Halsbereich?
Nein.
Ich habe es hier so in Höhe der Brust.
Links.
Und wie gesagt, er ist auch im Rücken und ist auch vorne.
Wo er jetzt genau anfängt, kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Aber es tut eben auf der ganzen Seite weh.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie aber keine Verletzungen?
Sie meinen Unfall oder Sturz?
Ja, ja.
Sturzen oder Unfall.
Nein, ich bin nicht gestürzt in letzter Zeit.
Ich habe auch keinen Unfall.
Aber ich denke, eventuell, ob das mit dem Tennis zu tun hatte,
irgendwie eine Bewegung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber es macht mir eben Sorgen.
Es ist ja gut, dass Sie sich hier um mich kümmern und schon ein EKG
gemacht haben und so.
Wie war das EKG denn?
War das in Ordnung, das EKG?
Ja, alles sieht in Ordnung.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, Fröhsteher, meine Seite habe ich alle richtigen,
die wichtigere Fragen gestellt.
Fällt Ihnen etwas ein, das ich wissen sollte?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, es macht mir schon Sorgen, was das sein kann.
Ich denke dann immer ans Herz, weil das auf der linken Seite ist.
Und meine Nachbarin sagt auch, du musst dringend jetzt ins Krankenhaus,
damit das überprüft wird.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen,
Frau Stegermann zu uns zu kommen.
Jetzt würden wir einige Untersuchungen durchführen,
um Ihre richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Okay.
Ja.
Gut.
Das können wir so tun.
Rima.
Ja, dann haben Sie jetzt ja noch etwas Zeit,
zu sagen, Ihre Vorstellung vorzubereiten.
Denken Sie an die Fachbebrüfe, die da vielleicht ins Spiel kommen,
die Schmerzlokalisation angeht,
vielleicht den Schmerzcharakter,
die Vorgeschichte mit den Operationen und so weiter.
Gut.
Und sonst würde ich Kollegen bitten, wenn Fragen sind
oder Ungleiten sind, bitte die Fragen jetzt noch zu stellen.
Vielleicht haben wir etwas Entscheidendes vergessen.
Ja, offenkundig waren die Kolleginnen und Kollegen alle zufrieden
mit ihnen, dass sie die richtigen Fragen gestellt haben.
Das kann sein.
Aber lassen Sie sich ruhig noch etwas Zeit.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Nee, also ich habe nicht richtigen Tiefen Husten.
Ich musste vorhin einmal, nachdem ich geduscht hatte,
einmal niesen und so etwas husten.
Und das tat dann sehr stark weh.
Da hatte ich sehr stark Schmerzen beim Niesen und beim Husten.
Aber sonst habe ich keinen Husten, kein Problem mit Husten.
Danke schön.
Hat jemand Fragen?
Ja.
Herr Kollege, brachen Sieseits?
Rein können wir anfangen.
Ja, gut.
Ja.
Schönen Abend, Herr Obatz.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Sie heißt Nadine Stegermann.
Sie ist 53 Jahre alt, 1,68 m,
um 66 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns seit 4 Stunden bestehende
linksseitige Toreologie
vorgestellt.
Die Patientin beschreibt diese Schmerzen
von den Rückenbereich
bis zu den Brustbereich.
Sieht habe.
Und wenn die Schmerzen
verschlimmen,
sich die Schmerzen
wenn die Patientin tief einatmen
und bewegt,
diese Schmerzenlage abhängen.
Und die Schmerzcharakter ist stärkend.
Beim Husten
verspürt die Patientin auch Schmerzen.
Die Frage nach Verletzungen
oder Umfahl wurde vermeint.
Ich unterbreche einmal kurz und wiederhole mal,
was Sie mir bisher berichtet haben.
Frau Stegermann ist eine
53-jährige Patientin
in gutem Allgemeinen
Ernährungszustand,
1,68 kg zu 66 kg schwer.
Sie berichtet über seit 4 Stunden bestehende
Schmerzen links-Torakal
im Bereich der Brustwirbelsäule
bis Sternal reichend.
Sie kann den Schmerz aber
in ihrem Ursprung nicht genau lokalisieren,
wo er bindet.
Aber der Schmerz geht von der BWS
bis zum Sternal.
Der Schmerz verstärkt sich bei Inspiration
und Bewegung.
Er wird als stechend beschrieben.
Die Schmerzstärke
wird mit Sex angegeben.
Ein Schmerzstärke
Ein Unfall-Anamnese
oder Trauma-Anamnese wird verneint.
Was hat die Patientin denn
für eine Tätigkeit ausgeübt, bevor die Schmerzen kamen?
Sie hat Tennis gespielt.
Nach dem Tennis
hat die Patientin Schmerzen verspürt.
Sie ist bei den Tennisspielen nicht gestürzt?
Nein.
Sie hat die Patientin so etwas schon einmal gehabt?
Das ist das erste Episode.
Haben Sie bei dieser Art der Beschwerden
die Vitalparameter kontrolliert?
Ja, ich habe EKG verschrieben.
Ich schreibe.
Es ist eine Schmerzstärke.
Es ist eine Werte.
Es ist die Schwere,
ich schreibe.
Es ist eine Werte.
Ich schreibe.
Die Gewichtveränderungen, nauseher, Fieber, Schüttefrost, Nachschweiß und die anderen
Fragen wurden verneint.
An der Vorerkrankung leidet die Patientin seit vier Jahren arterielle Hypertonie und
seit sechs Jahren leidet die Patientin an Hypertose wegen Theroidectomy.
Ja, ist die Frage, ob es eine Hypothyriose jetzt ist?
Die Patientin, ich würde es etwas anders formulieren, die Patientin ist vor sechs Jahren.
An was operiert worden?
Theroidectomy.
Ja, und warum?
Also Stroma nodosa.
Ja, die Patientin wurde theroidectomiert vor sechs Jahren wegen Stroma nodosa.
Histologisch war es wohl gutartig.
Ja, die Patientin war gutartig und seitdem nimmt die Patientin eine Substitution von welchem
Präparat?
Helptorokosin 50 Mikrogramm, einmal morgens.
Um eben eine Hypotheureose zu vermeiden oder auch eine erneute Stromerbildung.
Bima, gibt es sonstige Auffälligkeiten bei der Patientin?
Hat die Patientin solche Schmerzen schon einmal gehabt oder ist das ein erstes?
Das ist das erste Episode.
Erstmaliges Ereignis.
Okay.
Also die Patientin ist kreislaufstabil.
Das EKG, das sie aufgenommen haben, ist in Ordnung.
Die Vitageparameter auch, das ist ja schon mal gut.
Hat die Patientin sonstige chronische Erkrankungen außer der Hypertonie und Zustand nach
Thereodectomy oder Thereoidectomy?
Nein, nein.
Das andere Operationen bei der Patientin?
Ja, also immer davon zehn Jahren wurde die Patientin eine Pandectomy durchgeführt.
Also mit altes Wolfjahr, immer altes Wolfjahr wurde eine linksseitige Handoperation durchgeführt.
Ja, eine Herneutomie.
Herneutomie, ja.
Gut, wegen Herne in Grün alles.
Prima.
Bei der Patientin?
Ja.
Da gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie in Anamnese?
Also bei der Familie Anamnese gab es sich, dass die Vater am Apoplex mit immer alt davon 80 gestorben ist.
Und die Mutter leider an Kokosartose, Konartose und ja, Konartose.
Ja, okay.
Und der Vater hatte der nur den Apoplex oder hatte der?
Er hatte alle Hypertonie, hatte er gelitten.
Ja, über Jahre, ja.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Also sie hat eine Schwester, die 55 Jahre alt ist, die ist gesund.
Sie hat auch einen Bruder, der 58 Jahre alt ist und leider an Arteelehypertonie.
Prima.
Gut, gibt es sonstige Auffälligkeiten?
Hat die Patientin über Hauterscheinungen berichtet?
Nein, also ich habe gefragt und sie hat verneint.
Ja, da könnten Sie sagen, die Frage nach Hautepfloristenzen wurde verneint.
Ja.
Wir haben der Patientin bestehen keine Hautauffälligkeiten im Sinne von
Röstenzen oder Rötungen.
Gut, das werden Sie ja noch mal bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
dann auch beunordentlichieren.
Gut, ja, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Also meine Verdachtdiagnose ist entweder eine Sonnensoße,
das ist die Beginn der Sonnensoße oder eine Intercosta neuvalgie.
Das Erste habe ich nicht verstanden.
Sona Zoster.
Parissale Zoster.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Sona Zoster.
Pneumotorax.
Ihr wird gerade im Chat gesagt, Pneumotorax?
Ja.
Okay.
Ptulrose.
Ja, Herr Ptulrose.
Herr Pstost.
Okay.
Also das natürlich, ich kann Ihrer Verdachtsiagnose der sogenannten
Interkostalinoralgie sehr gut folgen.
Wir sprechen auch von einem eventuell einer akuten Blockierung
im Bereich der EWS, der sogenannten Kostotransversalgelenke.
Das passiert sehr häufig, zumindest in der Praxis,
da tauchen viele Patienten auf, nicht so sehr im Krankenhaus.
Aber in der Allgemeinpraxis habe ich das sehr oft erlebt.
Die Patienten haben Schmerzen, beim Einatmen,
bei der tiefen Inspiration, beim Drehen.
Sie können nicht gut drauf liegen.
Und es ist dann oft eine akute Blockierung.
Das kann aus einer banalen Bewegung passieren,
aber auch wie etwas beim Tennis spielen.
Wenn man eine plötzliche Drehung oder Körperlage wechselt,
da kann das passieren.
Diese blockieren und die kann auch sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Und linksseitig denken Patienten immer an ihr Herz.
Und natürlich, und das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht,
dass Sie gleich die Vitalparameter kontrolliert haben
und einen EKG abgeleitet haben und so weiter.
Das muss man machen.
Ein Differenzialdiagnostisch kommt sicherlich
in die kardiale Ursache in Betracht.
Auch bei der Vorgeschichte der Hypertonie.
Da hat die Patientin einen gewissen Risikofaktor.
Ein Herbiszoster kann sein,
aber ganz schnell,
dass er inspiratorisch Schmerzen plötzlich macht
und relativ schnell macht, ohne Hautepfloreszenzen zunächst.
Aber ein Herbiszoster ist gemeint.
Er kann solche Sachen emitieren.
Diese Schmerzen können den Hautepfloreszenzen
auch um Tage vorangehen.
Also, dass erst die Schmerzen sind,
und dann irgendwann plötzlich kommen die Pläschen.
Da muss man sicherlich dran denken.
Aber wichtiger ist jetzt erstmal,
keinen Herzinfarkt zu übersehen.
Auch keinen Pneumotorax.
Da gab es dort auch einen Hinweis,
dass es nicht nur eine Pneumotorax gibt,
sondern auch eine Pneumotorax.
Auch das kann durchaus,
denke ich, solche Schmerzen mituntermachen.
Aber ich denke, wir haben am Anfang
erst mal die richtigen Wegweiser gemacht.
Wichtig ist,
erst mal die vital bedrohlichen Dinge auszuschließen.
Das wäre ein Coronasyndrom oder ein Pneumotorax.
Diese Dinge sollten nicht übersehen werden.
Da kann man auch mal einige Stunden erst mal abwarten.
Schmerzmittelgabe geben.
Aber man sollte erst mal eine Herzkreislauferkrankung
und pulmurale Erkrankungen ausschließen.
Aber sehr häufig ist es eben die sogenannte Interkostalneurologie.
Die eben wirklich einstrahlt.
Und wenn man die anderen Dinge ausgeschlossen hat,
kann man auch durch eine geschickte Manipulation
dann den Patienten sehr schnell helfen.
Aber das würde ich erst immer dann machen,
wenn ich mir sicher bin, dass es nicht vom Herzen kommt.
Sonst kann das fahrlässig sein und fatal sein.
Das ist ganz klar.
Aber ich denke, das haben Sie sehr ruhig und dargestellt.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik dargestellt.
Ich konnte Sie sonst auch gut.
Ihre Sachen konnte ich gut nachvollziehen.
Und Sie haben die Patientin, denke ich, auch gut befragt.
Bei sowas immer auch an einen Unfallereignis denken
oder zumindest befragen Richtung eines Stürzes
oder einer Verletzung vor.
Das kann ruhig einige Tage her sein.
Das ist mal ein Sturzgab.
Denken Sie daran, manchmal ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie bei einem befragen die Hand vor den Mund nehmen.
Ihr habt mich das nicht vermerkt.
Dann verstehe ich Sie nicht so gut.
Okay.
Die Person, die die Hände möglichst nicht ins Gesicht nehmen.
Okay, okay.
Aber das ist einfach, ja.
Das ist der Stress.
Das haben Sie aber nicht oft gemacht.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst von Kollegen noch irgendwelche Ergänzungen,
das es noch an Diagnosen sein könnte, diese Beschwerden?
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Ja, das ist das.
Die Beschwerden haben wir etwas vergessen.
Ich glaube, es sind die wesentlichen Diagnosen.
Wenn man dann nicht weiter käme,
dann gibt es vielleicht noch irgendwelche anderen Dinge.
Aber ich denke mir, dass kardiale Abklären,
das pulmonale Abklären.
Und bei der klinischen Untersuchung
werden Sie wahrscheinlich feststellen,
dass es gewisse druckschmerzhafte Punkte gibt
an der BWS,
an den Kostotransversalgelenken
oder ilio-kostal-
Kostotransversalgelenken.
Da gibt es oft schmerzhafte Druckpunkte,
dass die Patienten dann sagen,
auch das tut weh.
Und dann strahlt der Schmerz auch
am interkostalen Nerv oft lang bis zum Sternum.
Das ist ja häufig.
Ja, prima.
Dann würde ich doch sagen,
haben wir das erstmal fertig für heute.
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe es im September.
Ach so, 16.
Ich glaube, das haben Sie mir schon mal gesagt.
Ja, ja.
Gut.